bienvenidos en este vídeo hablaremos
ahora sobre el ejercicio y para ello
tenemos varios puntos aquí dibujaré a un
señor de palitos que ya los conocíamos
antes y este señor está estirando el
estiramiento es un ejercicio
importantísimo y mucha gente lo olvida y
es entonces cuando suceden los esguinces
o los calambres y así el estiramiento se
ha de hacer cinco veces por semana más o
menos 30 segundos por cada grupo
muscular más adelante veremos en otro
vídeo cuáles son los grupos musculares
por el momento quedémonos con esto como
nota es importantísimo que estos
estiramientos siempre se hagan sin
rebote la intención de ellos es que
lleguemos al ejercicio y salgamos del
mismo estiramiento de manera suave
y también que todos estos músculos estén
calientes antes de estirar así sin más
es importante hacer una caminata o subir
y bajar escaleras o tal vez estar en la
bicicleta a unos 5 minutos antes de ahí
nos vamos a otro ejercicio que este
señor de palitos estará
puede ser caminando o corriendo no sé de
qué les da imaginación que esté haciendo
estos ejercicios son aeróbicos y estos
se deben de hacer alrededor de 5 veces
por semana es decir que los mantengamos
incluidos dentro de nuestros ejercicios
normales y normalmente se requieren 30
minutos puede ser nadar correr y bailar
hacer zumba ustedes sabrán son 30
minutos por sesión después de los
estiramientos para que estemos ya
calientes y lo divertido de estos
ejercicios de aeróbicos
y lo divertido de estos ejercicios
aeróbicos es que normalmente se pueden
hacer en grupo con compañía y así
bueno vámonos con el tercer grupo de
ejercicios el cual tiene que ver con la
fuerza o resistencia nuestro señor de
palitos estará cargando aquí estás pesas
y estos ejercicios de fuerza o
resistencia se hacen dos veces por
semana ok pero es importante chequen que
estás dos veces por semana son alrededor
de 10 repeticiones
está pasando un avión no sé si lo
escucharon o que recemos son más o menos
10 repeticiones por grupo muscular
y por grupo muscular nos referimos a tal
vez brazo o pierna o pecho seguramente
han visto en los gimnasios que dicen hoy
me toca pecho o mañana me toca pierna la
intención de ello es separar los
músculos y llevar un buen control vamos
a poner una nota aquí porque es
importantísimo que descansen por favor
el hacer los ejercicios de fuerza y
resistencia al menos requieren un día de
descanso si ustedes se saturan las
posibilidades de que sus músculos se
están lastimando son muy muy altas por
favor tengan mucho cuidado y descansen
una vez por semana
este descanso por semana es por grupo
muscular ojo no me vayan a salir con que
no van a hacer nada el resto de la
semana ok si hiciéramos una rutina
semanal se vería así este triángulo va
en subida y nos indica que estaremos
haciendo el calentamiento ustedes ya
conocen esta parte del calentamiento que
hablábamos hace un momento
empezaremos con una caminata o la
bicicleta a unos minutos tal vez cinco
diez y después nos vamos con el
estiramiento este será nuestro otro
cuadrito amarillo de estiramiento para
después seguir con los ejercicios
aeróbicos
una vez que ya hice natación o baile o
como les decía no sé spinning o algo así
haré después mis ejercicios de fuerza o
resistencia pongámosle la r estos
ejercicios serán de hombro elijo que mi
primer ejercicio sea de hombro y al
terminar volveré a enfriar este
triángulo ahora va de bajada y eso
implica que enfriar hemos los músculos
poco a poco esto también para evitar
lastimarlos si calculamos cinco minutos
de estiramientos 30 minutos de aeróbicos
y unos 20 o 25 de resistencia tendremos
el total de nuestra rutina cubierta en
una hora digamos que esta es la rutina
del día lunes
al día siguiente regresó al gimnasio y
vamos a hacer otra rutina volveremos a
empezar con nuestro calentamiento
nuestro triángulo de calentamiento
estiramos
y luego haremos ejercicio aeróbico hoy
va a ser martes y haré
natación
esta vez tendremos este cambio dado que
hicimos ya resistencia un día anterior
ahora descansaré mis músculos y lo estoy
haciendo muy evidente
esto será el martes y el miércoles
de una vez pongamos el jueves
ahora como se verá nuestro calendario
del día viernes empezamos con el
calentamiento seguimos con el
estiramiento y ahora nos vamos a los
ejercicios aeróbicos así es que será a
zumba
y después de tener varios días de
descanso puedo hacer otra vez
resistencia tomaré los mismos músculos
que ya descansar durante dos o tres días
ok ahora haré el enfriamiento y con esto
tengo mi rutina del día viernes
se dan cuenta como tuvimos un par de
días de descanso bueno de hecho tres
días de descanso de los músculos del
hombro es así importante que los dejen
descansar tampoco significa que no hagan
nada tenemos varias claves
importantísimas para el momento de hacer
ejercicio la primera y principal creería
yo que es que se mantengan hidratados
este es un vaso con agua y por favor el
hecho de que ustedes se mantengan bien
hidratados permitirá que los fluidos de
sangre y oxigenación en su cuerpo sean
los adecuados y por lo tanto evitemos
desmayos o evitemos fatigas e incluso
esos mareos que muchas veces en los
gimnasios vemos a la gente mareada la
segunda es por favor distante con la
ropa indicada
lo indicado para hacer ejercicio es
hacerlo con ropa cómoda y finalmente y
también importantísimo es ser razonables
este es un cerebrito estoy haciendo un
cerebro y le pondré raso no hable
ok la intención de esto es que ustedes
tengan ideas y usen la razón de tal
manera que si están lastimados digamos
de la rodilla por favor eviten los
ejercicios que tengan que ver con la
rodilla la intención del ejercicio es
mantener la salud e incluso mejorar la
condición física por favor sean
razonables con ello y cuídense